what is your favorite Starbucks drink if
you go to school I like the passion
Tango lemonade okay okay what are your
hobbies I like to dance can you show us
your best dance move
no music oh my gosh no music
I don't know no music
[Applause]
thank you guys you're really pretty I
didn't get all cools but that's okay I'm
so cool in my own heart you look like
you're into zodiac signs I am do you
like crystals I'm not a crystal person
what do you like to do for fun I usually
like reading
you have great energy and I just think
you're like such a nice person and very
positive I think you're a very nice
person very cool but um books
I sneeze sometimes you know what two out
of three I'll take it